alors réussir ces travaux moment d'abord
j'ai une caisse
vous posez
vous connaissez le jeu pile ou face
ouais
vouloir attraper et après on fait quoi
non on la pause où on garde dans la main
et après entre nous c'est quoi pile mais
sérieusement au moins quand j'étais
gamin je jouais comme ça je connaissais
absolument pas les règles et je ne
connaissais absolument pas les
terminologies est alors quand on
commence un chantier en fait beaucoup de
gens jouent exactement la même chose
avec le chantier on ne connaît pas
exactement comment on fait les choses
on ne sait pas forcément parlé avec le
professionnel et ça c'est un vrai
problème à l'heure pile ont réussi les
travaux effacé ben c'est un échec total
un vrai désastre
la première expérience que j'ai eu en
tant que professionnel et dans le monde
du travail
ça a été de travailler avec un
architecte qui m'a demandé une chose
regarde comment on pas comment on
communique avec les entreprises avec les
différents intervenants avec les
différents bureaux d'études et sur moi
un truc pour qu'on puisse améliorer les
règles et les relations parce que dans
dans l'observation que moi j'ai pu faire
c'est que en fait à 80% des problèmes
d'un chantier à l'autre est exactement
les mêmes le problème c'est que c'est
pas les mêmes intervenants et c'est pas
du tout le même personnel qui va ensuite
travaillé sur le chantier c'est-à-dire
les ouvriers et quand vous avez une
hiérarchie qui fait que l'information
doit être répercuté entre trois quatre
cinq voire six personnes ban a forcément
on perd l'information et c'est ça le
problème donc communiquer mieux et on va
voir comment on peut faire pour
communiquer son chantier quand on est un
particulier qui ne connaît absolument
rien et ça c'est pour vos parents c'est
pour vous également quand vous rentrez
chez vous que vous avez ensuite les
partiels qui arrive juste après les
vacances
parce que là quand vous avez de la
poussière partout dans tous les cours et
bien je suis sûr que ça vous embête un
petit peu la première chose quand on
veut faire un des travaux c'est de
décrire ce qu'on veut faire
alors tout le monde s'est parlé de son
projet je suis sûr que vos parents vous
vous communiquez sur les travaux que
vous avez envie de faire dans la maison
dans l'appartement mais l'écrire il
illustré qu'est ce que ça veut dire mais
ça c'est une 2e étape d'abord on
commence à le parler et ensuite on
commence à le décrire ça c'est un
document que moi j'utilise dans ma
société
c'est juste un document word doc word ça
veut dire que tout le monde peut le
faire tout le monde peut le modifier et
tout le monde peut utiliser cet outil là
pour décrire un projet et ça je peux
vous dire que les entreprises apprécient
quand vous avez un plan avec des
éléments qui sont à noter sur un plan
qui sont localisés dans telle pièce je
veux faire le carrelage je veux refaire
l'escalier je veux enlever par exemple
les barreaux de l'escalier sur la
première photo en haut à droite
là on sait de quoi on parle et quand
vous avez cinq six entreprises qui
viennent sur un projet simplement pour
voir si on peut effectivement réalisé
quelque chose et à quel coût
eh ben les six entreprises n'ont pas le
même projet en tête
vos parents par exemple où vous quand
vous présenter un projet que vous nous
avez uniquement le vecteur parole pour
le communiqué vous allez parler de votre
de votre projet avec quelqu'un mais avec
une autre personne vous n'allez pas dire
la même chose
l'écrire ça permet d'avoir quelque chose
qui est carré qui permet aussi d'avoir
quelque chose pour lesquels on va on va
ensuite avoir exactement les mêmes
éléments à communiquer à tout le monde
et c'est ça qui est important à avoir
exactement les mêmes éléments à
communiquer à tout le monde
montrer des photos c'est bien les
modifier c'est mieux quand on peut
montrer sur une photo ce qu'on attend
effectivement de quelqu'un d'une
entreprise et là c'est très important
parce que quand vous avez un maître
d'oeuvre qui arrive et que vous lui
dites me tiens on veut démolir tel parti
on veut démolir une terrasse par exemple
et enlever un barbecue
quand vous avez les ouvriers qui arrive
derrière ils ont pas forcément
d'information c'est quoi le barbecue
c'est quoi la terrasse moi je n'ai
jamais vu incontournable
quand on a la photo et quand on est
capable de montrer la photo ensuite aux
ouvriers mais ont ils savent quoi faire
directement
et ça ce sont des éléments qu'on ne
montre pas simplement aux chargés de pro
mais qu'on montre aussi aux ouvriers et
qui peuvent ensuite resté sur le sur le
chantier sur le site et qui sont
accessibles à tout le monde première
chose communiquer mieux moi décrit les
choses ont décrit ce qu'on veut faire et
ensuite une fois qu'on a décrit il faut
commencer à communiquer sur la manière
dont ça va être fait n'est pas
simplement d'un point de vue technique
mais surtout d'un point de vue humain
parce qu'un des éléments qui fait qu'un
chantier se passe mal c'est aussi que
humainement ça ne passe pas forcément
avec les ouvriers ou avec les personnes
qui vont traiter le projet pour vous la
poussière c'est le premier élément
je suis sûr que vous avez déjà fait le
ménage dans votre chambre ou chez vous
vous faites le ménage
le jour d'après ou trois jours après
vous avez des invités qui viennent et en
fait juste avant vous avez une
entreprise qui revient faire des travaux
qui promet toute la poussière je suis
sûr que ça vous énerve un maximum donc
ça ce sont des choses qu'on essaie de
communiquer c'est principalement au
niveau des durées des échéances des
dates je parlais des cours que vous
aviez des partiels que vous pourriez pep
que vous pouvez préparer ça sont des
éléments qu'on communique aux
entreprises et qui ne sont pas toujours
fait bon
la plupart du temps on les communique
une fois qu'on arrive à terme
et là c'est un vrai problème parce qu'on
ne sait pas gérer l'urgence donc sans le
communiqué avant et moi je met d'un
élément qui s'appelle les 7 questions
qu'on va avoir dès avant de signer un
devis avec l'entreprise elles sont on
peut le trouver sur mon site internet ou
dans cette question là il y a quatre
éléments que je donne simplement pour la
forme pour les évoquer par exemple la
courtoisie la propreté les normes les
assurances civile et décennale attention
toujours deux assurances une civile une
décennale civile c'est pour le chantier
en lui-même la dsna c'est après une fois
que l'entreprise est partie le contenu
de vie là c'est pour cette raison que je
décris le projet avec des images avec un
plan où les éléments sont localisés sur
le plan le contenu des devis je suis sûr
que la plupart d'entre vous vous n'êtes
absolument pas capable
parés de devis entre mêmes mois avec des
entreprises qui vont travailler chez des
particuliers parfois comparé deux vies
entre c'est très très compliqué donc
d'avoir un document cadre qui présente
tout le projet ça permet d'avoir un
contenu de de vie dont on sait qu'il va
correspondre à ce qu'on attend et ça
nous permet aussi de ne pas comparer les
devis entre eux mais de comparer surtout
le devis chacun des devis à ce qu'on va
attendre de l'entreprise techniquement
c'est pas intéressant d'aller à comparer
un devis par contre on veut savoir ce
que veut ce qu'on va faire et quelles
vont être les éléments finaux qu'on va
raconter recevoir les délais également
ce que je conseille surtout dans ce
document là c'est de prévoir un tiers de
délai supplémentaire pour soi même c'est
à dire qu'on ne dit pas à l'entreprise
mais on demande à l'entreprise de finir
peut-être vingt jours avant qu'on ait
une échéance au total par exemple si
vous avez des partielles à faire eh ben
on va demander à l'entreprise de finir
20 jours avant les partiels comme ça si
un souci mais vous avez toujours aux 20
jours dans lesquels vous pouvez gérer
les problèmes
le dernier élément que je voulais
communiquer c'était le suivi de chantier
le suivi ça demande une vraie présence
quand une entreprise fait des travaux on
fait quoi
ensuite on regarde ce que l'entreprise a
fait jour par jour
jour après jour quand on rentre chez soi
et qu'on s'aperçoit que l'entreprise a
fait des choses qui ne correspondent pas
vraiment qu'est ce qu'on fait on appelle
l'entreprise on lui dit elle il y a des
choses qu'il faut corriger maintenant
qu'on s'énerve au téléphone et
finalement ça mène pas à grand chose
quand on s'ennuie quand on s'énerve au
téléphone l'entreprise bat lui aussi il
est le gérant de l'entreprise il est
aussi avec sa famille avec ses enfants
il n'a pas forcément envie de sanglots
téléphone est passé ensuite une mauvaise
soirée et en plus ce que vous allez lui
dire il ne va pas forcément le
communiqué à ses ouvriers pour le
lendemain
donc c'est là que des photos des
éléments qui peuvent être gérés
exactement comme la description de
projets vont être pertinent localiser
les éléments qui son arrêt
lisez et mettre des photos par exemple
là sur ces photos là ces deux photos
d'un escalier du même escalier est ce
qu'on veut faire c'est simplement et
rasé une marche salle expliqué au
téléphone ça va mais s'assurer que
l'information hi du contremaître
jusqu'aux ouvriers qui ne parlent pas
forcément le français ça c'est plus
compliqué c'est là qu'on passe par les
photos et là tout le monde se comprend
la photo c'est l'élément essentiel pour
que tout le monde puisse se comprendre
j'ai installé sur mon téléphone
l'alphabet russe ce gvt est un ouvrier
qui ne parlait absolument pas le
français ni l'anglais est le seul moyen
de communiquer avec lui c'était le russe
mais quand vous communiquer uniquement
avec du russe et sans photo parce que
vous n'avez pas le temps d dit et c'est
très compliqué et gémit peut-être une
heure à comprendre ce qu'il essayait de
me dire et moi à me faire comprendre sur
un élément basique
la faute aussi direct alors tout ça
c'est bien
ces trois éléments essentiels c'est très
bien mais pour moi ce n'est qu'un début
parce que le rêve c'est qu'à travers
douze étapes un particulier qui ne
connaît rien du tout aux travaux
puissent décrire son chantier géré le
les travaux recherchez une entreprise
signé avec elle avec un un sentiment de
sécurité et surtout être capable
également de maîtriser les coûts de son
projet et les éléments administratifs
tout ça à travers douze étapes
c'est assez ambitieux mais c'est le rêve
et peut-être qu'avec ça on pourra enfin
arrêté de jouer à pile ou face avec les
travaux et qu'on pourra améliorer les
chantiers qui se passe aujourd'hui je
vous remercie